Bard.
Witch.
What are you doing here?
And what fresh hell
did you just crawl out of?
A sewer.
What's your excuse?
Oh, a sewer, I always knew you
were a blood sucking joyless…
hugger.
One of my favourite things
about shooting Season 2
was the fact that I got
to work with Anya again.
Witches are bound to bump
into monsters eventually.
Jaskier.
Yennefer.
Oh, she’s so scary.
They’re frenemies,
first and foremost.
That’s what we discover
in Season 1 anyway.
I hate to break it to you,
but that ship has sailed,
wrecked, and sunk to
the bottom of the ocean.
Ow.
In Season 2, they’ve both lost
someone very important to them
and I think that really connects them.
We’re better off without him.
Anya and I are good pals
and we get on really, really well
and by the time the scripts landed
and we saw we had
a lot more to do together,
we really wanted to dive into
what made these characters tick
and why this unlikely reunion came about.
I would not wish that fate
on my worst enemy
and yes you are…
firmly lodged in that category,
it has to be said.
It feels light-hearted with Jaskier.
They just enjoy
playing with each other.
You both smell truly awful.
All the insults hurt sometimes, because
of Yennefer’s many insecurities.
I mean it is like something crawled
up your arses and died.
We used to send texts to each other
and I remember texting her going
If I were to insult you, if
Jaskier were to insult Yennefer,
what would be the most hurtful thing?
What would hurt her?
And then I went to Lauren and was like
Look, when I’m adlibbing or improvising,
is it alright if I take this in a new direction?
We wanted to show these
characters understood each other
perhaps better than even they know
and they have this innate ability of
being able to hurt each other emotionally.
You know, once upon a time, I would
have used this opportunity
to call you an empty, lonely,
power hungry she-demon.
There’s love there, deep down.
But, they soon realise
that’s not enough.
In the world that we’re experiencing,
in the Continent that is
collapsing around our ears,
two people who have lost something
are brought together by their own tragedies.
It always feels light-hearted
and I think that’s what makes
them so strong as a couple,
to watch rather so exciting.
Hang on, what are you going to do?
What witches do best.
Make a potion.
I always feel in incredibly good hands
when Anya is on the set
and she’s just an absolute delight
and an incredible talent.
I’m so lucky to have worked with her.
Chaos could never be done
with the likes of you,
Yennefer of Vengerberg.
Of that much, I am certain.
So if it’s all the same to you.
Goodbye.
Good luck.
Good riddance.
Same to you.